nos dicen que el polígono q es una copia
escala del polígono p usando un factor
de escala de un medio a qué fracción del
área del polígono p corresponde el área
del polígono q pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo mi mente trata de
hacer esto un poco más tangible una vez
que tengamos práctica podremos hacer
esto sin necesidad de dibujos pero ahí
nos hablan de polígonos arbitrarios p y
q así que hagamos uno simple como
estamos hablando de áreas me gustaría
revisarlo con rectángulos porque es más
fácil pensar en áreas de rectángulos
vamos a ver el polígono q es una copia
escala del polígono p así que comencemos
con el polígono p y lo haré con rojo
polígono p voy a crear un polígono
arbitrario así que digamos que este es
nuestro polígono y voy a crear una
escala de un medio de modo que haré que
sus lados tengan una medida cómoda de
números pares digamos que este lado mide
4 y este lado es igual a 8
este es el polígono b es un cuadrilátero
de hecho es un rectángulo
y su área es igual a 4 por 8 que es
igual a 32 ahora vamos a crear el
polígono q y recuerden que el polígono q
es una copia a escala del polígono p
usando un factor de escala de un medio
así que lo vamos a escalar a un medio de
modo que este lado en lugar de medir 4
va a medir 2 y este lado correspondiente
en la versión escala va a ser igual a 4
aquí lo tenemos lo hemos escalado a un
medio y ahora cuál es el área bueno este
es el polígono q nuestra área va a ser
igual a 2 x 4 que es igual a 8 ahora
fíjense que el área del polígono q es un
cuarto del área del polígono p y eso
tiene sentido porque cuando escalamos
las dimensiones del polígono en un medio
el área va a cambiar en un factor igual
a esto al cuadrado un medio al cuadrado
es igual a un cuarto de modo que el área
cambió en un factor de un cuarto otra
manera de responder esta pregunta es a
qué fracción del área del polígono p
corresponde el área del polígono q
y la respuesta es un cuarto del área del
polígono p y la gran conclusión aquí es
que si escalas algo si escalas los lados
de una figura en un medio cada uno el
área va a ser igual al cuadrado de eso
así que un medio al cuadrado es igual a
un cuarto si la escala es igual a un
tercio entonces el área va a estar
escalada a un noveno si escalamos a dos
entonces el área va a aumentar en un
factor de cuatro hagamos otro ejemplo
aquí nos dicen que el rectángulo n tiene
un área de cinco unidades cuadradas
jaime dibujo a una versión a escala del
rectángulo n y la etiqueta como
rectángulo p aquí lo tenemos esta es una
versión a escala del rectángulo n que
factor de escala uso jaime para dibujar
el rectángulo p a partir del rectángulo
n vamos a pensar en esto aquí nos dan el
rectángulo p y vamos a pensar en sus
dimensiones la altura es 1 2 3 4 5
altura igual a 5 y tiene 12
es 456 789 de ancho y el área es igual a
45 ahora el rectángulo n tiene un área
de cinco unidades cuadradas vamos a
escribir esto para ir del área de n al
área de p estamos multiplicando por un
factor de 9 si vamos de un área de cinco
unidades cuadradas a 45 unidades
cuadradas el área del rectángulo n es
igual a 5 unidades cuadradas el área del
rectángulo p que calculamos aquí es
igual a 45 unidades cuadradas aumentó en
un factor de 9 ahora cuál será el factor
de escala si nuestra área aumentó en un
factor de 9 bueno ya hablamos
recientemente de la idea de que el
factor en que aumenta el área es igual
al cuadrado del factor de escala
así que una forma de pensar en esto es
decir el factor de escala al cuadrado es
igual a 9 otra manera de pensar en esto
es nuestro factor de escala es igual a 3
para ir de n
ahora vamos a verificar que respondimos
la pregunta vamos a dibujar un
rectángulo a partir del cual si lo
escalamos en un factor de 3 obtenemos el
rectángulo p de modo que su base es
igual a 3 en lugar de 9 la base es algo
así y la altura en lugar de ser 5 será 5
tercios la altura será algo así se ve
parecido a esto 5 tercios nuestro
rectángulo n se ve así y cuál es el área
bueno 5 tercios x 3
es sin duda igual a 5 unidades cuadradas
fíjense en esto cuando el área aumenta
en un factor de 9 el factor de escala de
los lados es igual a 3 para ir de 5
tercios a 5 multiplicas por 3 y para ir
de 3 a 9 multiplicas por 3
y terminamos